ladies and gentlemen now that i'm a big
shot daily youtuber i decided it was
time to come
clean on all the times i've been wrong i
know you're thinking
never no i've been wrong one time
2020 there was a little bit of a blip in
my in the error of my ways
when i told caleb maddox that he was
wrong you guys don't know who caleb
maddox is
he's an 18 year old life coach he's got
it all figured out
and when he told me that reddit videos
were
in his words the greatest opportunity of
our era
i said are you joking prepare yourself
greatest income opportunity of our
generation reddit videos it's the
opportunity of our era
and honestly he kind of fled away from
the internet i actually feel bad about
it to this day
i reach out to him daily saying caleb we
need the yta method back
but the truth is jokes aside i think he
was actually right
looking at all the big daily youtubers
you got pewdiepie
k-s-i a lot of eyes you got video game
dunky
okay all these daily youtubers who are
crushing it right now in the views
what do they all do reddit video
actually video game dunky doesn't do
credit videos
that defeats my role but the point is a
lot of these big youtubers they do
reddit videos
why because it makes damn good content
you get content to react to you guys get
to interact with me i get to interact
with you
so because of that i've seen the light
look going daily
things have changed around here in the
coffeezilla 10 million dollar studio
a lot of things are going to be changing
in the future too but i've really taken
a
new look at a lot of things that i used
to make fun of and reddit videos
is one of them so if you'd like to
participate in a new segment on our show
you can go here it's coffeezilla
underscore
gg here it is boys right now it's an
unofficial reddit i'm trying to talk
with the moderator who created this uh
to try to make it the official reddit
but anyways this is where you're gonna
post and you know what to kick it off
just so you guys just to give the people
who created this
a little bit of a a head start i'm
getting everyone
who's not a bot free reddit gold that's
right
gold boom gold for you sir
gold for you gold for you coffee zilla
vs dean graziosi
a mindset coach's reaction we'll give
you that gold for that
listen it won't be always this easy to
get gold ladies and gentlemen
but for now it is look at this gold gold
some of these are bots
some of these posts have been deleted
but look undead marine
hey coffeezilla featured on
ballerbusters ig gold
another one gold you guys get the idea
even the comments steve jobs mentored me
but actually just an
honor doctor hey gold now that is the
exact kind of reckless
reddit gold gifting you can expect if
you join the unofficial
but now official subreddit of the coffee
zilla coffeezilla underscore gg
join now submit your memes i have a
feeling this is gonna just turn into
people making fun of me
for being a hobbit for having a large
head i don't know
but uh i think it'll be fun anyway i
think it'll be a fun time
now thank you for sitting through that
little
pitch fest now let's talk about caleb
maddox again
because yes he's a man of wisdom now i
realized i was wrong about him in fact
not only he's a man of wisdom he's
actually back he took a little siesta
after our talk
a break but he's back in action and he's
better than ever ladies and gentlemen
he started something called maximum wage
okay so let's listen in and figure out
what's going on
congratulations you have officially
finished the mentality portion of
maximum you know when people like
they graduate in college there's this
big gathering everyone fills the stadium
they all wear their cap let me guess
maximum wage is just like that
well i honestly believe like this is
just as big of a deal this is a bigger
deal than that because what you guys
learned in this what it set you guys up
for how
this is
my gosh it's no it's not it's not as big
of a deal as college
what's this kid's name ryan or something
ryan come on ryan
get it together next you're going to be
comparing it to harvard
how is that you guys have to make
maximum wage is so much more important
than anything you could ever learn in
college
the life skills that you learn are way
more important than anything you'll ever
learn in college
truthfully like you just said i really
believe that what you guys learn at
maximum wage is more valuable
than spending 30 years at harvard
[Music]
hold on let's go back i just have to
hear that again that what you guys learn
at maximum wage is more valuable
than spending 30 years at harvard
he's learned nothing guys i thought
caleb maddox picked something up from
the whole yta disaster
but he's saying that this new class that
class
greatest opportunity of our era this
class more important than 30 years at
harvard
this is a guy who's never been to
harvard but it's more important than 30
years at harvard i'm so sick of this
kind
look i know college is too expensive but
these people are ridiculous
now that's not the only uh caleb maddox
take that i was kind of surprised by
there's actually another caleb i gotta
say even though you were right about
reddit
um what is this the real pandymic
is the spreading of a victim mentality
caleb medics
if he wasn't so young i think this would
be funnier i think we all understand
that caleb maddox is definitely
approaching a point in his life where
he's gonna realize a lot of the stuff he
said
when he was younger was dumb so i'm not
gonna vault him too hard for this
but caleb uh just
i don't know thank goodness i wasn't on
twitter when i was that young
because i probably would have said some
dumb stuff too but wow that is a bad
take
okay well there's your first meme boys
i'm giving you that one for free
go to coffeezilla underscore gg if you
want to meme along with me
i'll see you there and i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
you